[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
borosch and this is
how to become a grand master
this time we are going to look at a
special prodigy although we all going to
look through different journeys of
people getting to the top
of their game and becoming a grand
master the first one we're going to talk
about is richard robot the rise of the
raw port
now
i want to start off with
a little bit of a puzzle then we're
going to take a look at the game itself
this one has been featured
between banus and rapport so it is black
to move
and it is evident that rapport is
dominating here however
rapport finds the strongest continuation
which practically ends the game
now for all of you who don't know
rapport he is one of the youngest grand
masters of all time he became a
grandmaster at the age of 13 and 11
months so super young
just like many others
including the one here in saint louis
leoniznick who was a grand master at age
14.
so
and that's a journey also that we're
going to take a look at see the
struggles and the successes of how he
eventually actually reached grand master
hood but for now we are going to look at
some critical games that he played
for him to become a grandmaster
meanwhile hello everyone over here and
hello chat
great to see you being the gm in the res
not quite this is a lesson of its own so
this will be something you'll see every
wednesday
so it's interesting
there was a message which is in the
right direction so one of the things
that you should be looking for in these
puzzles is to look for loose pieces and
targets so one of the biggest problems
that white has is discoordination
of course you can't say the same thing
about black's position black has a
beautiful knight on d5 a beautiful queen
on e2 you can't really say the same
thing about white's position as the
bishop and the king are somewhat well
it's relatively the best piece white has
but it's still kind of uh firing away at
a non-target it's kind of
a passive bishop but the same thing
about the queen on d8 that queen on d8
is actually undefended
so there is actually a way for us to
take advantage of her situation
and of course any ideas are welcome
queen d1 okay queen d1 check
by al hajj
and if i would continue with king g2 so
check
i would go king g2 here
was happy to win the bishop well it's
good to win the bishop but hey if you
can win something
uh bigger
and half tier you should go for that one
and if i capture
it's h3 i captured
oh
before
yeah
it's actually an interesting move
however white does have the threat of
giving a perpetual so you don't really
have the time for that because they just
keep checking you
but queen d1 is indeed the right way to
go king g2
and
yep knight e3 or yup it's a check and
there goes the queen
chat is correct as well knight takes f4
is just as good maybe also wins a pawn
but
what matters most that this is just
completely winning and of course
richard won the game
so this was a little bit of a puzzle
from the game that we are actually going
to take a look at
this has been played
in the third event
of
the third norm so anytime you're trying
to become a grand master you've got to
win three events and this was the third
one for richard so he had to win it
score a lot of points and if he does so
reaches
the rating of 2500 he will be
come a grand master
so not f3 knight f6
c4 c5
not something unusual now for the
initiated look at the rating of white
and the rating of rapport
banus is actually
much higher rated at this moment but as
you'll see rapport does not pay
attention
for the ratings so knight c3 knight c6
d4 take sticks e6 and this is actually a
very very famous line this has been
featured in plenty of candidates events
both of these players are professional
bonus actually
became a member
of the hungarian team as well as
rockport of course
and
for
argument's sake bishop f4 d5 knight b5
e5 takes
takes takes this has been featured in
the candidates tournament between viktor
korchnoy and portish
korchnoy who would celebrate his
birthday today
now in this game vanus chose a3 which
wants to restrict rapport's play of
bishop b4 which is a typical idea
as black would try to ruin white
structure
so a3 is interesting and in fact a court
is not a favorite too
e3 bishop e7
e4
castles
so if you look at this position
what can we sort of notice
why did get the center control but what
is that one little thing that white is
lacking
and not that i did too many things wrong
i may add
rapport had two gm norms yes and also he
had many rating points in the bag
already
so these are the ratings at the moment
and the schedules like i think it's
monthly now
so you get the ratings out monthly but
before that you could get in a bulk so
they would calculate four months of
results altogether
he could have been much higher rated but
it doesn't show
so why did play plenty of pawn moves
very good observation there al hajj
the pawns take away too many moves so
because of that
white's king is sort of in the middle of
the board
and rapport is trying to
counterbalance this with active play so
he goes for quick castling and in fact
wants to play this pawn break
so if banos doesn't really react goes
bishop to e2 he goes immediately with
this break
and according to recent theory this is
supposed to be very much fine for black
as
white loses the grip of the center no
more of this marotzi stranglehold in the
middle
and
probably the game sort of evens out as
white manages to castle but loses the
control of the center
now
obviously as banus is an ambitious
player and higher rated at the moment
wants to keep the tension and goes for
knight to c2
knight to c2 is a weird looking move but
it makes sense if white would face d5
then
this would be captured and might just be
up
pawn
so knight c2
and here rapport
does some of the people's favorite
and i wonder if you guys know this
typical setup when either there's an e61
or b6 one and there's also a g6 b6 which
was an orion favorite andrasadorian's
favorite who was i believe the second of
kasparov at the carp of kasparov matches
so do any of you know
what are these structures called
in this system
this is one of those elusive
animal named openings
it's the hedgehog yes
and it's called the hedgehog because
it's spiky it's very very difficult to
get to
and they actually pack a punch as you'll
see in this game
so
bonus sort of
feels the dangers sees that d5 might be
coming soon so it's going for f4
so if rapport tries to break free with
d5
he might just go nah ah i'm gonna push
my pawn to e5 and push you back
so f4
and rapport
very
elegantly and rightfully so keeps on
developing
bishop b7
bishop d3 now the fight really revolves
around who controls the middle and
whether white can control the center
that he has because with big center
comes big responsibilities
so banus is actually quick to over
defend the e pawn
f4 seems to be a little bit too much not
really that so i think f4 is ambitious
yes
it does weaken this diagonal but there
aren't really any easy ways of
exploiting that if black would go
something like bishop c5
then
white would just chase the bishop away
and once
banus would consolidate white is just
much better because of the extra space
and no real easy counterplay
so
first thing that we can learn from
robport use quick development it can't
really hurt you yes you have a little
bit less space
but
you're up ahead you have something to
play for you have that king in the
center that you can fight against
so rook c8
queen e2 and it's very interesting that
bonus rift uses to castle
and it's just waiting and just over
defending all these crucial squares
it's a big strategical battle going on
all right so here we have to look
for a different way
for us to break through
because apparently d5 still runs into
ideas of either takes
takes e5
or e5 immediately
so is there anything else we could try
to target
in this hedgehog position
so there are a couple of things you have
to know about the hedgehog
that uh all the trumps and the benefits
of the position oh were you
about to raise your hand sorry no okay i
misunderstood the cue
in any case
in these positions
these pawns are strengths and their
weaknesses at the same time
so
your goal should be to go
after either or
the f1 isn't really that important it's
more mostly like a side pawn
which just helps white kind of have a
grip on the position but otherwise it's
not a point of contention
we could play for some sort of ideas of
a6 and b5 that is again a typical idea
and you're sort of getting closer to
what rockport did it is the c4 pawn
that rockport is going to go after
knight to a5
and knight 285 is actually a
multi-purpose move
it puts some pressure on e4 but it also
puts pressure on c4 not to mention
the sneaky little threat of double
attacking the rook on a1 and the bishop
on c1
so he's winning a lot of time and also
putting pressure on bonuses center
so knight a5
bishop e3
and one thing is to kind of strike the
right direction but really following
through what makes a grand master a
grand master as rapport will show in
this game he goes bishop a6 and
this wasn't just a fed he's actually
going after the c pawn
so now banus counter punches
because he notices that otherwise this
could become a big problem
knight e8 and in fact and this is what
makes the hedgehog so inviting and
interesting to play as black that even
though now white grabs a lot of space
black will always get a chance to
undermine it with d6 and in very rare
cases with f6 because mostly use that
pawn to defend your king it's a guardian
pawn these guys are guardian pawns you
really don't want to push them too much
if you don't have to
it's an ip5
so it's still a very tense situation and
it is for now for us to try to find what
rockport played here
that's very logical what rockport did
so one of the crucial things in chess
is to wonder why they played the move in
the first place very good chat so the
first thing you check out is hey knight
b5 looks defensive right it looks like a
defensive move
well not at all it's not only defending
it's also attacking that pawn on e7
so it's multi-purpose just like the
moves that rockport played himself
now
that pawn
is a side pawn so we're not gonna break
down in tears if we lose it
but if we make a random move they might
as well just take it
so your next move has to be energetic
and aggressive
d5 very good i've seen plenty of d6s
i've seen d5 i've seen knight b3
d6 feels a little
too timid
d5 is even more aggressive because if
you take here i will always be able to
take on c4 so you take here i take here
and your knight is trapped if you take
here i go c takes d3 and i'm going in
with my attack let me even check here
first
and then take on d3 with plenty of forks
and a king stuck in the middle
and um
this play actually unsettled banos a lot
who's a grandmaster obviously
here he thought oh i got to go for a
solid move which was a mistake and
one of the specialties
of these budding super gms as rockport
is
that they know how to up the stake
so here actually instead of the move
of c takes d5
bonus could have played
a very brave move
something that you wouldn't even think
of
at the first go
but if you've seen
enough
superhero movies you might actually do
it
long castles
an insane move which i don't fault bonus
not finding and the whole concept is if
you take on c4
bishop takes c4
rook takes c4 this looks completely
losing
for white
however white has this very nice
tactical shot of queen takes c4
because of this pin
takes rook takes
bishop takes knight takes and this turns
out to be
good for
white because these pieces are a little
bit awkward
otherwise the bishop pair would
definitely compensate
for
these weaknesses on c4 and b6
however
he got completely unsettled by rapport's
very energetic and aggressive play which
is the staple of his game right to this
day
and decided to go for the safe approach
of taking on d5
queen takes d5
knight b4 he's clearly trying to stave
away from all the complications
bishop takes b4
a takes b4 and we're sort of reaching
the second phase of the game
first we had to unsettle our opponent
and get a fighting position which
rapport managed to do so
but this is the second part where you
actually have to find a way to
capitalize of all the gains you got
yeah knight b3 is a good idea however i
may take your bishop
in that case
but you're looking at the right
direction
and i'm not sure if i'm telling a big
secret
even grand masters they start off
looking at candidate moves that may not
actually work
but then they realize hey
what if i do an l reverso
and then things start clicking
so we can't quite go knight to b3 knight
c4 yet
yeah our problem mainly is that this
bishop is in the way
so
we don't have time people we don't have
time to waste here no time to lose we
got to capture
captures
knight b3 and before we've been kind of
crying about the a7 pawn
but with the king stuck in the center
and our pieces swarming on in
taking here is no business because i can
go in id for at least
forcing you to trade otherwise you lose
the bishop
and with your king stuck in the middle
your pawns v con f4 and b
f4 and b4 you're actually
near lost
because strategically rapport is just
outplaying his opponent
all those pawns that used to be strong
that f-pawn
and even a little bit on the queen side
what a good grip
not anymore they're just targets
so actually he didn't go knight b3 he
went for knight c4 but it's kind of like
the same idea
knight c4 takes rook takes castles
and now we're dominating we have much
better piece placements
however there is
a couple of pieces that rapport will
have to improve if he wants to win this
game
so first we have to identify
the pieces that are terrible
and then look for a solution
the knight on e8 is
kind of bad
kind of bad there
but if we could have a little dream can
dream a little dream
where would we put that night
yeah that night is absolutely terrible
swanisa i agree
here
okay
which we could get via knight c7 knight
b5 knight d4 yeah for sure
any other ideas
where this knight would be happy to go
to
and find a chill spot
on
f5
although it's a bit more difficult to
get there because the pawn does take
away
they're out
and normally we wouldn't want to touch
these pawns these are guardian pawns
they're there to protect the king
we shouldn't move them
if not necessary
however
in chess
you can move your queen right
so you could get to d5 and that's
exactly what rockport does so it goes
knight c7
rook c1
trades trades
queen d7
and now the knight is hopping to that d5
square
and usually we talk about
positions like more closed positions
where the knights dominate the bishops
but here it's even better than that
because
all of these pawns are on dark squares
sort of limiting that bishop
so this is from a
psychological and a positional
perspective
is a complete triumph
by
richard
queen c4 now richie hops into d5
bishop f2
and goes knight e7 trying to control
this file
g3 and i really don't like this move of
g3 g3 looks logical
uh white is trying to over defend
however
look at this diagonal it becomes all
opened up
so rook c8
queen f1 takes takes h5
and rapport is taking full advantage of
that
establishing a very good position for
the knight on f5
and of course also d5
queen c4 check here knight d5 and
funnily enough
the material is even
yet
black is completely winning because that
bishop on f2 does not have a single
target it can't blast through
those pawns
this knight is monstrous on d5 and this
king is absolutely weak
queen c8 here queen e8 queen e2 you
don't really have time to take here
because i have knight e3 check here then
there is mate
if you go here
i don't even bother take the bishop and
it is checkmate
so he went king g1 and this sort of
transposes
to the puzzle we started out with
after h4 queen d8 there was queen d1
check and here white obviously resigned
seeing if he goes king g2 there's knight
f4 and he's gonna win the queen
so what did we learn and what is our
getaway from
this game
by rapport
well
he built up an aggressive position
and
sort of believed in the dynamics of
chess
he sacrificed the center
for quick development king safety and
lots of aggressive play
against the e4c4 pawns
and why just couldn't withstand the
pressure and was just too solid in this
occasion
yeah and in this case
i just got overwhelmed
so apart from this game i definitely
wanted to show you this other one where
yep go ahead
what was white's decisive
mistake i do believe
that it's around here
and
c takes d5
is sort of the turning point
in every chess game there is a critical
moment
and this was the critical moment where
the whole game shifted in rockports
yeah
so c takes takes
maybe knight b4 wasn't exactly the best
move but
from here on out rapport never gave a
single chance and
great point there because this is move
15.
and after move 17 oh it's over
you're done rapport isn't going to give
you a second chance
you made two inaccuracies
and we're done for
so let's look at another game by rapport
where he faced
vargazoltan another grandmaster
and i want you to show this
that
yes
these players are amazing but it's not
like that these games are not hard
fought the other one
was more one-sided but this has some ups
and downs so d4 d5 d take c4
all you queens gambit fans you can
rejoice
because this was
a queen's gambit
e3 c5 takes
this is the main main main line of the
queen's gambit bishop d3 knight c6
knight c3 and incidentally just recently
ding lyren played this
in the magnus event
against jordan fun forest
whom is of course part of the big
dynasty
of
the forests he is a chess plane that is
a chess playing dynasty i believe i did
a lecture on that too so if you're
interested to know more about the 1800s
uh forests well knock yourself out and
take a look
any case back to this game
knight c3
in that game
i believe jordan played c takes d4
here varga played the rare move of
bishop d7
and
here's the point of bishop d7
black wants to go castle but if he goes
now bishop e7 white would capture here
and practically you lost the tempo
and this is actually like those little
grandmaster struggles
he's saying nope
i'm not going to give you a free tempo
if you want to take be my guest
but then i actually managed to develop
my bishop as well
but rapport caves in and says well i'm
game
i'm i want to see you lose that tempo
if you want to develop i'm not going to
help you
got to do something varga says no
i'm not going to move that bishop unless
you capture my pawn
interrupt word goes okay
deal
because i have the idea of b4
i've got this cute little idea of b4
winning time now this wasn't as good
earlier for white because he didn't have
a way to gain time
because now black will have to respond
to this b4 idea
bishop d6
in fact here
rapport had a tactical opportunity
but
he just doesn't take it
i wonder if you
guys and girls
can
see
the move here
dynamics are hard because you can't hold
on to a dynamic advantage yeah you got
to transform it
like you have to transform it like
rapport did
creating a tangible advantage
of having a knight in the center
but back to the skin
yeah there is this idea of bishop takes
a6
which is a very funny looking move
and if pawn takes then there's queen
takes d6
that's not something you
see most of the time
of course it's not lost for black black
can counter take on h2 and you get a
weird position
um
and who knows who's really benefiting
from this because
white will lose
upon on the king's side while gaining a
majority on the queen side
however rapport
is very bent on
going for
his plans so he's never steering away
from his concepts he's always following
through and i think that's one of his
biggest strengths
that he's not going for
ah maybe my opponent missed the free
pawn so i'm just gonna do that but he's
just following through the plan that he
already set out to do
queen e7
no more trickies
rook c1 very straightforward play just
getting all of them pieces into the game
castles
now if you go b5 you actually help
black
to go after the a pawn
you can't really go e4 because that
would blunt your own bishop
which of course you don't want
what you really want to do or ought to
do
is to activate your bishops as much as
possible
that is our dream
so it is for you people to try to find
this next move by a rapport
and this is actually a very very nice
maneuver
slash plan by richie
and mind you if you're just dilly
dallying in this position as white your
advantage will slowly evaporate
you're mostly better because black is
yet to finish the development in this
position
okay knight a4 is interesting
however you're moving the knight away
from the critical zone
which will be in the middle of the board
we're not really going to play on the
queen side more in the center and on the
king's side
it's not the move that he played but
knight e4 is a typical idea in a very
sound move
opens up both bishops and eliminates a
very good defender
like these are usually very very
pleasant positions
he actually played something very
similar he played knight g5
and the idea is
to eventually play knight e4
but with a little bit of more oomph in
the position
so let's say black completely ignores us
then we may go knight e4
and we have even more pressure on the
gnh pawns
now of course
varga saw all of this and played knight
e5
in rapport
again
comes up with a vintage rapportean idea
thinks outside the box
and comes up with another original plan
so whenever you see a move you always
have to ask yourself
why did
zoltan play knight e5 what was the
purpose of that move
well the purpose of it all is to try to
eliminate this bishop before it could
cause
a ton of trouble
but rapport ignores it
and that's a very unique decision
bravely just foregoing the bishop and
saying hey
your pieces
are so awkward
it's the momentum that counts
and
not really the bishop pair
so
after the trade he is going for this
knight ce4 plan so basically
substituting the bishop for the queen
and the queen is going to act like the
bishop in this position
so rook d8 knight e4
takes takes and
everything is working like
clockwork
for richie
because the queen
is double attacking both the h pawn and
the b-pawn at the same time
and if you hadn't noticed it yet
one of the ways to win a chess game is
to double attack
sometimes you can win
just by the strength of your position
but most of the cases 90 of the time
it's a double attack
because
physically your opponent
has difficulties
of defending both at the same time
now vodka plays f5 which is a great move
says okay i'm going to lose the b-pawn
but at least you're not going to
checkmate me because if he goes to g6
well you are running the risk of getting
mated on the dark squares
f5
queen takes b7
and
a lot of times
in chess literature
they say and the rest is technique you
may have heard yasir say that and the
rest is mere technique
however
the game doesn't really end there
there's still a struggle
as there is still some hope for black to
survive
and black keeps on trying plays a5
so even though
it's beyond doubt
that rapport
is the one calling the shots
however black has
something to brag about himself what is
those things that actually is looking
okay for black
or is sort of an advantage that he can
play on
and it's also a fisher favorite mind you
not really we do have some pressure
on those pawns for sure
but what it is that kind of gives
a sliver of hope
for varga to survive
is the bishop there exactly
so even though
black is worse just down upon
he still has something to hope for
because this bishop if it opens up can
in the long run attack these guys so
there's some hope
rook takes bishop takes takes sticks and
so far so good
by richie
however richie here
i'm not sure if he played the right move
i believe he should have taken the a
pawn
bishop c5 and just trade because one of
the things that you should do and always
try to follow through
is to go for more trades now this is
somewhat
obscure
but if rook takes then there is rook b1
and this a pawn combined with the v king
should
possibly lead to a win for rapport
sooner or later
so bishop divorce is actually the hard
move so the funny thing about chess is
that even when you're winning
there could be some moments you'll have
to get into tank and try to find
the correct solution and bishop d4 is
not an easy move to make because it does
give a pawn back
otherwise b takes a5 is
not a move that you'd naturally play
because it sort of invites bishop c5 and
it looks like a doubled pawn
i mean he played b5 which doesn't spoil
anything however i feel b takes a5 might
have been an easier way
bishop takes
f takes
so we again talked a bit about
defensive skills
in chess
and just defending positions
what do you think
would be the best chance for black here
to go for
what would be
a good defensive idea here
and of course when i'm talking defensive
i could also just mean being offensive
you could try to trade the rooks
and then get into the opposite color
ending
that's one way of playing
so even if you get a position like this
you still have to formulate a plan
even though you're the inferior side you
decide who's trying to hold it all
together
just because you're down upon does not
mean
you just have to focus on defense
bishop b7
yeah
yes
so exactly like that
white is going to face
an aggressive rook and bishop combo
on the second rank and this is a typical
play which i highly advise of any levels
to try out bishop and rook combos are
pretty good together
and even though rapport is still winning
um
the winning like the technique and the
situation is getting a little bit
messier
so rook c1 and of course
vargo goes rogue d2 so of course white
is winning but it's not as simple
anymore
bishop e5 very good move by richie
he's saying even if you take this and
you take that
now you no longer kind of endanger my
king and i have enough time to activate
my rook and then just go b6 and run my
pawn down combined with the threats on
the g pawn
two threats at the same time
coincidence
i think not
so
vargas is okay i don't wanna
get into that business i'm gonna go rook
d5 and go after your b-pawn
rook c7
defending with attacking because this
was a double attack by varga
but his way of defense is to
counter-attack himself
zeruk takes e5 rook takes b7
rook takes e3
and notice that earlier on we said oh
free pawn for richie
easy win
now we're in a rook and game
not such an easy win
still winning no doubt but there's just
more technicalities
in the position however this is a better
ending that you usually get
and i want to ask what is that huge big
difference
between this position and the rook end
games
we usually get
in our own events
there's something that's just much much
better for richie
the king is cut off yes that's one thing
but that's not the only thing
it's not just the fact that the king is
cut off
but you're kind of going in the right
direction
that's it king limitations so yes
partly that the king is cut off but also
the fact that the king is on the 8th
and a lot of times these rookan games
would be just straight up drawn if the
king wasn't stuck there and i'm going to
show it to you so rook a7
and if black would take a3 we can go b6
rook b3 b7 and most 99 percent at the
time
this is not a problem for black to hold
because this pawn can't go any further
however because of the unfortunate place
of this king on g8
white is just straight up winning you
can't go here because i just promote
with a check
hit your rook hit your king
and otherwise my next move is going to
be rook a check
and b8 queens
so you have no ways of stopping me and
it's all due to this bad king placement
so remember this if your opponent king
is on the first
or the eighth
your chances of winning a rook pawn
ending is much much higher
so that's actually the reason
why varga chose rook b3 here
a4 f4
and um
this is the second moment
i really wanted to ask you guys what
would you play here
as white
not nothing spectacular
just end game principles because those
exist as well
and well said rookie 7 is a very precise
move
and one thing that makes richie such a
great player is his precision
although
this will be sort of
a mixed bag
and makes fortunes but that's sort of
part of the deal
but rookie 7 was very accurate i agree
and rook c7 as well double attacking
so what could i mean
by end game principles
what do you need to have in order to
have a successful end game
we've got that we've got the past pawn
we've got an active rook right
so there's a third one that we'd need
and then the situation
is just going to unravel in our favor
an active king
he really should have brought his king
over
and then the game would have been over
pretty soon
because his active king is just going to
guarantee him
victory he instead went for h4
which
is an exciting idea
but maybe not as good as bringing the
king in if you could choose
bringing the king in you should
not saying that h4h586
doesn't have
a d plan and in fact everyone is
like padding computers in the back
virtually virtually only
but
you can see that richie
at the age of 13 11 months
he does push h4h5h6
so maybe this whole plan
wasn't so new after all
now the whole concept is the following
he's trying to
put even more pressure on that king on
g8
and on these spawns on h7 and g7 so e5
h5
and for example if black would ignore
all these white could go g6
take sticks and already you have this
mating idea
if you go here i check you
if you go here
i have this method of again threatening
checkmate and trying to take the e pawn
so
rook f7 k8 rook takes g7 and of course
this is winning because you not only
have
one passer with the b pawn but another
one with the g pawn
so of course varga wants none of this
business g6 h6 and he's establishing the
same thing
e4 and here actually
richie makes a sub-optimal move but
let's be fair here with the players
which oftentimes just doesn't happen
that much
time trouble we're on move 32 they reach
control at 40 where they get additional
time
here of course he should have gone rook
g7 check
and then after you go here here and
you're just winning the same way we
discussed
but
nerves is part of playing a grandmaster
event
don't forget
this is for grandmaster norm
she plays rookie 7 and rookie 7 turns
out to be not so good in fact
if
here black found the move e3
king f1 rook b4
this probably is closer to a draw than
anything else because suddenly black
will have counter chances the rook and
pawn
and you don't really have enough time
anymore to win the pawn there
but of course both of them in time
trouble plays rook b4
b6
rook takes b6 rook takes e4
rook b4
so for
now we have to find
the way to win for us
i could even imitate
a time trouble situation you've got 15
seconds
14.
rookie 7 okay
12 seconds
eight
seven
six
give a check okay five
four
three
two
one that's it that's all the time you
have you don't have more time to spare
you flag you lose the game so he did
find rookie eight so that was correct as
danny pointed out
rookie a check
king f7
and in the nick of time
richie gets towards the h pawn wins the
h pawn
and this is actually the benefit
of pushing the pawn up the board not
only do you have some mating patterns
but that pawn is very very very close to
promote
so rook takes a four
check
king g8 now this is not your traditional
situation
usually you get
only an h pawn there which isn't
quite enough however
in this case this pawn is protected this
is a protected passer so it's even
better
and his position by now is again
completely winning
king g8 check
rook takes g6
rook a3 rook f6 and here black resigned
because next move is going to be g6 and
there is absolutely no way you can stop
me and even if you go here i go check
you
here and i could
just queen and style with rook f8 the
rook obviously is taboo because i
promote with a check and it is game over
so i really hope all of you enjoyed
this lesson of how to become a grand
master
as we discussed
couple of critical games
of richard rapport who became a
grandmaster at age 13 11 months
so i hope to see you guys in the future
as well with many many more journeys to
come thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you